your new documentary man tell us about
that oh
yeah so you know it's out there already
i mean
it was a journey i do ketamine in it
like through
a doctor's office make you feel ken
doctor's office i did it with the doctor
and then uh
they did a do you write out the
conscience so there's
one where they do it intravenously and
then you just pass out which is in the
movie but you see me
a little bit before i go under but
the other way is by iv still and then in
the doctor's office
but then you have a therapy session so
it's just trippy because you're having a
therapy session
you know and it's a dissociative
anesthetic so it essentially takes your
like separates you from your ego more
yeah so then you're starting to deal
with stuff and then i had this thing
where i was thinking about my
relationship
and my parents relationship and my then
i started thinking about my parents
relationship and i was determined i was
feeling all this heaviness
and then it occurred to me they're both
dead and i was like
god bless you and i love you but you're
gone so let's
let's lift that too like i don't need
your
marriage like pain anymore you know and
that actually freed me up a little
i don't know who knows what any of this
stuff works i'm just trying to
figure it out